at the US has announced plans to
maintain a peacekeeping group of 200
troops on Syrian soil beyond the plan
but through a Pentagon troops from the
country this spring the statement does
come after a recent phone call between
Trump and his Turkish counterpart Fresa
Burdwan the leaders discussed security
in the region there are currently some
2,000 American troops in Syria in
December Trump announced the rude rule
of US forces there but their pullout
does now seem less than certain it
should be formally announced sometime
probably next week that we will have a
hundred percent of the Caliphate but I
want to wait for the official word you
don't want to say it too early we have
one against Isis we've beaten them and
we've beaten them badly
now we've won time to give up rave
warriors in Syria a warm welcome home
you could in that vacuum see a
resurgence of Isis see a resurgence it
will come back if we have to okay let's
get the thoughts now of international
affairs commentator Jonathan Steele he
joins us from the UK
Jonathan good afternoon to you some
might ask what is the point of keeping
just 200 troops in Syria I mean how
effective could they be well they're a
tripwire I think I mean the main problem
is that the Turkish authorities
President and Iran has threatened to
move Turkish troops into the whole of
the northern Syrian area to wipe out the
Kurdish forces there which he considers
to be terrorists I was talking actually
yesterday in London to one of the Syrian
Kurdish political leaders who was here
on a visit to see the British government
and she was saying that the Kurds
are willing to move their forces five
kilometers back from the syrian-turkish
border provided there are peacekeepers
or some international force in the
buffer zone to protect them against the
Turks so do you think we'll have seen
there are discussions going on in
Washington about all this and obviously
with Moscow and with their 2:1 and we'll
see what comes out of it oh sure I mean
this latest announcement did come after
both with erdowan do you think it's a
deal that they struck then no no I think
it's too early to strike a deal I think
they're as I said their consultations
going on involving the Syrian government
in Damascus Moscow Turkey Iran which is
part of the Astana
process and of course the United States
and British and French forces who are
there in a small capacity backing up the
Americans there are many competing
interests aren't there in Syria do you
ever foresee a situation where there
would be no US troops well I mean Trump
has said that they've defeated I US and
they have done militarily in the sense
that they have almost no territory left
the last sliver of territory probably
will fall next week as Trump said but
that doesn't end the ISIS problem
because they're huge number of former
fighters and other sympathizers with is
who are perhaps willing to go
underground to form sleeper cells to pop
up in different parts of the world
particularly in Europe
maybe in Russia maybe in North Africa
and carry out their terrorist attacks so
the ideology continues even if the
territory has been lost sure wouldn't
the Syrian government lower the Armed
Forces they have be enough to counter
that problem
well they they might be but as I said
this isn't just a military problem it
requires education it requires
de-radicalization it requires jobs I
mean one of the reasons why many of
these young men joined this group is
economic they have no work prospects no
jobs they join IRS and then they become
radicalized afterwards it's usually that
way around it's wrong to think of people
are radical islamists then join Isis
it's often particularly the ones who
local the Iraqis and Syrians young
unemployed young men who then become
radicalized once they've joined is sure
we shouldn't forget all the thousands of
radicalized Islamists that have come
from Europe and the UK too well that's
exactly right and some of them have come
back some of them have been put on trial
got sentences of two or three years and
then we have these cases of the so
called jihadi Brides like SH Mohan Bagan
the teenage London girl who went out
there at the age of 15 and now has wants
to come back and has had her British
citizenship taken away sure it's a
complicated situation isn't it Jonathan
always good to talk to you're gonna have
to leave it there that was Jonathan
Steele international affairs commentator
you